hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna do
another dark season3 video in my last
one I looked at the big questions after
season 2 and in this one I'm gonna talk
about all the behind the scenes photos
that have come out from season 3 filming
and what they might all mean there's
quite a few of them and they bled to a
lot of theories so I have to give you a
spoiler warning here you don't like
seeing production photos and speculation
based on what's coming out of the set
while they're filming season 3 of dark
then this video definitely won't be for
you I'll put a link at the top of the
page to my spoiler free season 3 video
and you can watch that instead with that
out of the way let's get into it because
there's a ton of these photos to look at
so if you follow dark showrunner on
Instagram you'll notice that he likes to
post a lot of photos of the actors while
they're on set shooting if you don't
follow him or visit reddit very often
then you're in for a treat here and you
should probably consider looking his
Instagram account up because he's been
posting season three images nearly every
day since they started shooting a couple
weeks ago I think there's about 40
images here we had to go through and the
first thing that comes to mind is that
on top of the different time periods to
keep track of we're also gonna be
getting a look at the world where alt
Martha comes from the first few pictures
we saw made that pretty clear as alt
Bartos has long hair magnus has dark
hair and tattoos alt Martha has bangs
which we saw at the end of season two
and rather than seeing Jonas in this
group we see this new actor Sammy who
seems to have taken his place in this
world in the next image we see Jonas
with the scar around his neck with the
alts which seems to set aside any doubt
about where alt Marta took him to save
him from the apocalypse Claudia told her
younger Jonas that she'd seen a world
without him and these shots from season
3 make it feel like we're gonna probably
see that too while there's no guarantee
that this world doesn't have a Jonas
come along I definitely don't see any
pics so far that strike me as being of
an alt Jonas there are plenty of photos
of these characters around town and at
the school and in my opinion most of
them seem to pick up with Jonas and alt
Marta right after the events of the end
of season 2 so theory
no real big surprises here the alternate
world is different than the binden that
Jonas grew up in the actress who plays
Francisca is missing from these filming
shots so it's definitely possible that
she doesn't exist in this world either
since there's no Jonas it was speculated
that there would also be no Mikkel but
Oliver Masucci who plays Ulrich posted
this photo on his Instagram which has a
shot of a younger child from behind in
these photos we see alt Katarina
who also has bangs and all Ulrich and
they look like they are married in this
world too everyone looks slightly
different but they should be relatively
familiar to us as viewers and be a good
guide for Jonas who is familiar with the
Nielsen family in his world
I mentioned Francisca is missing from
the alt world but we have one photo from
her post apocalypse based on her
clothing it looks like she may spend
some time in the 1950s the last time we
saw her she was with stranger Jonas
getting ready to leave 2020 we presumed
that she was the unnamed older woman who
is with older Magnus in 1921 in this
photo of the set dressing room probably
confirms that reddit user Sandra Renkin
pointed out that if we look closely at
the family tree that is hanging behind
Roman Niska in this Instagram post
there's a photo of that actress in
Franziska section this seemed likely to
begin with but it's still nice to have a
little confirmation in Romans photo we
also noticed that he has one brown
contacts Dylan this seems to go hand in
hand with the other presumption most of
us had that this man in the cave was
older bartosh considering that Paul Lux
who plays the younger has brown eyes
I already got into this in my last video
so no need to rehash it
but the competing theory that I don't
subscribe to is that Adam is actually
the older Bartos rather than Jonas
either way the picture of forensics get
looking like she's wearing 50s clothes
is interesting because we now feel
confident that she'll be headed further
into the past
that there could very well be several
jumps in time before they settle and
inform sick mundos there's 33 years of
aging that has to happen many fans have
brought up the idea that they could end
up in 1888 and grow into the people we
see in the 1920s the one picture we've
seen of stranger Jonas from season 3
filming could be hinting at that as well
in the photo his clothes look to be of a
much older style and until we see more
of these characters that seems to be
consistent with them being in the far
past speaking of the 1950s we know that
Hannah was in 1954 at the end of season
2 and we have some season 3 photos of
her that indicates she will be spending
time there this photo sparked one of the
most interesting theories I've seen so
far when you look closely she's wearing
the st. Christopher medallion that Jonas
finds at the lake in episode 6 of the
second season in that same episode when
they're swimming in the lake bartosh
tells a story to Marta about a woman
drowning there so when this photo popped
up with her wearing the medallion reddit
user Maria Nyota Ross put two and two
together and posted a theory that Hannah
will actually drown in the lake in the
1950s and that will lead to the legend
that the kids know about in 2019 I think
it's interesting I mean at the very
least Hannah seems to be the first owner
of the medallion which plays an
important part in Jonas and Marta's
relationship and we even see down the
road that Adam still is holding on to it
the fact that they mentioned someone
drowning in the lake could definitely be
connected but at the same time there are
many other ways that it could end up on
the beach that don't involve Hannah
drowning I'm definitely not ruling this
out it's a good idea at the same time
I'm also not convinced that Hannah's
story ends with her at the bottom of the
lake if she does then the original
theory proposes that Katarina might play
a role since we know that she's
time-traveling as well she left 2020 she
could arrive in the 50s looking for
revenge the other thing that season two
planted a seed for was Hannah starting
an affair with Egon Tiedemann and in
this set photo of the actor who plays
younger ego
he's sitting on a bed in the photos that
we see if they do get together and
things fall apart then he could be
involved with her ending but I don't see
him as a stone-cold killer and I guess
you know we should consider that she was
suicidal before she travelled to 1954
and there's always potential for her to
take her own life the ideas that go
against her dying in the 1950s are that
some people think that it's possible
that even though she's a little bit
older that she could still have another
child that would somehow figure into the
family trees and the other thing is that
a lot of people think that this new
actor that they brought on for season 3
looks like a good match for an older
Hannah either way I think Hannah will
play a big role in the final season and
I can't wait to find out what it is
Catarina's went about or something we
aren't sure of yet we do get some
pictures of her but I don't think that
we can say one way or another what time
period she's in based on what she's
wearing
I think it looks like she's made her way
to the hospital where they're holding
Ulrich but who could say how old her
husband might be when and if she sees
him again what would she even do
considering the situation I already
mentioned the shots of her that we saw
as the alt world character where her
family and hair looked a little bit
different and then we also got some
photos of the younger Katarina back in
the 80s in this image someone's
definitely standing behind her and to me
it looks like it could be the stranger
Jonas but there's no real detail to make
out who it is for certain in the photo
she's wearing a Walkman and once she's
staring up at the ceiling the Walkman
looks like the one Mads was found with
but I'm not sure if that has any
importance considering that all Walkmans
pretty much looked the same back then
from what I remember beyond that we have
a few other shots that aren't really
clear as to what significance they might
have we have a couple of Charlotte who's
looking normal as if she didn't go
anywhere after touching hands with her
mother / daughter during the apocalypse
this makes you think it's probably an
alt Charlotte in the other world but we
don't see her interacting with anyone
to make it clear I think the blurry
figure behind her in this photo is
probably an alt roller with no eye patch
but it could be an alt Clausen as well
there's one photo of her mother /
daughter Elizabeth who's still young and
she's wearing a sweater that we've seen
her wear before this is not what she was
wearing in the bunker when we last saw
her so there's no real evidence for
where or when that we can take away from
this shot the last pics I'm going to
talk about today are of the older older
still appears to be locked up in the
mental hospital in season 3 and to me it
looks as though he may have aged his
hair looks whiter but everything else
sort of looks the same so he still could
be in the 80s and it could be the
lighting in the photo or this could be
later on after he's still been there for
another period of time I think that's
enough for today let me know what you
think about these photos and if you've
been following them have ideas about
them what your theories are at this
point we still have a long time to think
about things until season 3 actually
arrives do you think Hanna having the
medallion means that she will die in the
lake what do you suppose is going on
with this buggy or cart or whatever you
would call it that all Marta and alt
magnets are riding around and when is
Katarina and what do you think she will
get up to do you think she'll actually
find Ulrich or will he end up dying in
the mental institution what are you
hoping to see in the next two months of
filming photos personally I'm hoping to
see more early sick Mundus teasers I'm
the kind of person that wants as many
spoilers as I can get as far as things
we can put together ourselves
flatout leaks of scripts or story
details kind of ruin the experience but
I'll gladly speculate on anything that
we can get our hands on and see that
gives us an idea of what might be coming
our way and I think yeah that's the most
interesting thing to me more of the alt
world obviously and then something back
in the past when this whole idea of sick
moondust is developing that would be
really cool but yeah let me know what
you think please like the video if you
enjoyed it give me any ideas that you
have about future videos about dark
please subscribe to my channel and
follow along
make sure you turn on the notifications
you know the drill as far as that goes
and thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon